سنتوجه مباشره الى متابعه هذه الكلمه
والمؤتمر الصحفي للاعب الاتحاد كريم
بنزيما وسيتابع معكم هذه التغطيه زميلي
محمد القناص اليك محمد
شكرا جزيلا بالتاكيد هذه اللحظات
التاريخيه بالنسبه لنادي الاتحاد انضمام
افضل لاعب في العالم الى صفوف نجم الفرنسي
كريم بنزيما الذي سيبدا مع الاتحاد مشواره
الجديد لاعبا للفريق
الاتحادي في المواسم الثلاثه المقبله
نشاهد الان على الهواء مباشره المؤتمر
الصحفي الخاص بتقديم كريم بنزيما في لاعبا
لناديه الاتحاد وذلك في مدينه الملك عبد
الله الرياضيه في جده
اذا الاتحاد يقدم لعبه للصحافه لعبه
الجديد نجمه الجديد
كريم بنزيما نستمع
اذا كان في ترجمه للمؤتمر الصحفي ام لا
اذا
لا يوجد ترجمه لكن نحاول بعض
الاجابات من النجم الفرن اذا
الاتحاد يقدم كريم بنزيما للرسائل الاعلام
الان قبل تقديمه للجماهير بعد قليل في
ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله الرياضيه في
جده اللاعب الذي
يمثل نادي الاتحاد في السنوات الثلاث
المقبله نستمع الان الى الاجابات بنزيما
في المؤتمر الصحفي
خلينا نتكلم عليها من الساحه داخل الملعب
وخارج الملعب
وان شاء الله
نبحث عن التطور نبحث عن
فعل اسم المملكه من افضل الدوري
وان شاء الله باذن الله انه القادم افضل
واجمل باذن الله
كريم
عن الاتحاد عن جمهور الاتحاد ايش اللي
بلغتوه عنه
نادي الاتحاد هو جمهوره اللي هو يعتبر
افضل جمهور موجود في الدوله السعودي حضور
قياسي وحتى اليوم ترى المعلوميه حضور
الجماهير اليوم في حفل تقديم اللاعب كريم
بنزيما يعتبر الاكبر في العالم من ناحيه
العدد واكيد طبعا الكريم يعني في ضمن
النقاش
تكلمنا عن جمهور الاتحاد والنجمهور الذهب
ومدرب مدرج عظيم واروح الاتحاد اللي طبعا
لا يضاه
حينما نشاهد كريم بنزيما مع الاتحاد
بالتاكيد النادي لديه طموحات كبيره تطلعات
كبيره ايش ممكن توجهون كلمه للجماهير
الحاليه طبعا اولا نشكرهم على وقفتهم معنا
ونشكره الجميع طبعا
اللي ساعدنا وعاونا في بداياتنا الحمد لله
احنا بعد اربع سنين يعني انجازاتنا الحمد
لله كان واضحه للجميع
طبعا سواء كانت بطولات او رعايات او
التعاقد مع لاعب كبير مثل الكريم بنزيما
القادم اجمل وافضل وباذن الله باذن الله
نادي الاتحاد يكون دائما الاول وزي ما حدا
يقول رؤيتنا انه نادي الاتحاد يكون افضل
نادي سعودي عالمي وان شاء الله باذن الله
راح نكمل التوفيق لكم ميرسي كريم
في ملعب مع المشجعين انا طبعا
لدي شغف كبير انضم الى الجماهير
ونتشارك معهم هذه اللحظه مع كافه الجماهير
والبلد بكامله اشكر ايضا رئيس النادي
والنادي وكافه الجماهير
المتواجدين ستكون لحظه رائعه وانا سعيد
جدا شكرا لك كريم
شكرا لكم على المشاهده نتمنى لكريم بنزيما
حظا سعيدا مع نادي الاتحاد ننتقل الان الى
الملعب مع الجماهير
اذن هذا كان الجزء من المؤتمر الصحفي
لتقديم كريم بنزيما حديثه كان عن تطلعه
لمواجهه او الانضمام الى الجماهير في
الملعب بعد قليل وتقديم مستويات مميزه
تليق
بانتداعبه الى نادي الاتحاد الرئيس
التنفيذي لنادي الاتحاد ايضا تحدث عن
اهميه انضمام كريم بنزيما على الجانب
الفني والجانب
المعنوي بالنسبه للجماهير والجانب
الاقتصادي بالنسبه
للنادي في احدث صفقات الدوري السعودي
للموسم المقبل سيكون كريم بنزيما
احداث الاسماء المنضمه الى بطل دوري
المحترفين السعودي نادي الاتحاد ليمثله في
المواسم
المقبله وهناك تراقب كبير جدا لجماهير
نادي الاتحاد في ملعب مدينه الملك عبد
الله الرياضيه الذي نشاهده الان من الخارج
لاستقبال احدث المنضمين الى الفريق نجم
الفريق الجديد افضل لاعب في العالم
2022 كريم بنزيما الذي سينضم بالتاكيد الى
نجوم نادي الاتحاد المتواجدين بلقب دوري
روشن السعودي في الايام الماضيه
قريب بنزيما اذا تحدث عن السعاده
بالانضمام الى نادي الاتحاد تطلعوا لتمثيل
الفريق في الموسم المقبل قال انه متحمس
لرؤيه الجماهير في
الملعب الجوهره وانه سيذهب اليهم الان
ليقابلهم في اللقاء الاول على ارضيه
الملعب الذي شهد الاسبوع الماضي تتويجا
كريم بنزيما عفوا تتويجه ناديه الاتحاد
بلقب دوري المحترفين
السعودي بعد غياب استمر لاربعه عشره
عاما عن التكييف بلقب الدولي طبعا الحضور
الجماهيري لا يقتصر فقط على الجماهير نادي
الاتحاد في هذه
المباراه اذا نشاهد عدد من الحاضرين
يرتدون قمصان نادي ريال مدريد النادي
السابق لكريم بنزيما الذي انضم اليه في
وتسعه وكان احد ابرز نجوم توج معه في 14
عاما بخمسه وعشرين بطوله منها خمسه القاب
لدوري ابطال اوروبا وايضا خمسه القاب لكاس
العالم للانديه وبقيه الالقاب تنوعت بين
دوري وكاس محليه وكاس سوبر وبالتالي تتطلع
جماهير الاتحاد لان يواصل كريم بنزيما
رفقه فريقها هذا
الاداء الكبير وهذه الانجازات الكبيره في
تجربته الجديده الاتحاد اذا انضمام كريم
بنزيما اليه سيكون
بمثابه التدعيم الاول للفريق في الموسم
المقبل فيما سيلحق ذلك عدد من التعاقدات
المقبله بالنسبه لفريق الاتحاد في الموسم
الحالي فتره الانتقالات
[موسيقى]
الصيفيه والتي ستعد بالكثير لنادي الاتحاد
نشاهد الحضور الجماهير قبل قليل في ملعب
الجوهره ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله
الرياضيه بجده صغارا وكبارا ذكورا واناثا
قدموا
للتحيه
والترحيب
بنجم الفريق الجديد مهاجمه كريم بنزيما
النجم
الفرنسي والذي كان ترك ريال مدريد
الاسباني قبل ايام بعد مسيره امتدت
لاربعه عشر عاما حطط فيها عديده
الانجازات وكثيرا من الالقاب الكبيره مع
الفريق
الملكي الجماهير اذا انتهتف بالنسبه باسم
كريم بنزيما ترحب به في هذه
[تصفيق]
المصافحه الاولى مع نجمها الجديده ونسمع
الى صوت الجماهير في
هذه
التغطيه والنقل المباشرون من ملعب مدينه
الملك عبد الله الرياضيه سمعنا صوت
الجماهير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رحب
دكتور تركي العواد محلل
النشرات والبرامج الرياضيه عبر قناه
العربيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور تركي ليله
كبيره جدا بالنسبه لناديه الاتحاد الذي
توج قبل اسبوع تقريبا بلقب الدوري السعودي
واليوم يستقبل احدث الصفقات المنضمه الى
الفريق مثل هذه الصفقه الدكتور تركي بعيدا
عن الفوائد الفنيه لها ماذا ستنعكس ايضا
على نادي الاتحاد وعلى جماهيره
اه هي لن تنعكس فقط على الاتحاد محمد
وجماهيره ومحبي نادي على الدوري السعودي
باكمله يعني صفقه كريستيانو كيف انعكست
على الدوري السعودي بالكامل وليس فقط
جمهور ويعني محبي نادي النصر فلذلك هي
صفقه للجميع قد نرى انها للاتحاد طبيعه
اللاعبين واستقطاباتهم ياتون لنادي واحد
ولكن الانعكاس الحقيقه سيكون على الكره
السعوديه بشكل كامل رفع مستوى الدوري رفع
قيمته السوقيه اللي دائما اتكلم عنها
واطلاق مشروع الاستثمار وتخصيص الانديه
الرياضيه ايضا تحدث عنها فلذلك هي صفقه
للجميع من الناحيه الفنيه ومن ناحيه
التسويقيه
تدعم الاتحاد ويعني هي هديه اخرى بعد هديه
الدوري واحتفالات الدوري وهو احتفال مستحق
الحقيقه لفريق
كبيره في كل مره ولكن يجب ان لا ننظر لها
على انها صفقه للاتحاديه فقط لا هي مبهجه
للجميع بغض النظر عن الانتماءات بالتاكيد
هذا ما يقوله حتى كريم بنزيما بالنسبه
للحضور الى السعوديه ويقول بانه وقع مع
الاتحاد لانه نادي لديه قيمه كبيره ولا
طالما كان يحرز التقدم ويتطور في الطموح
وبالتاكيد ان هذا ايضا سينعكس حتى على
الزملاء اللاعب في الميدان يعني احنا شفنا
موسم كبير جدا قدمها الاتحاد دكتور
بالحصول على لقب السوبر السعودي وايضا
بالحصول على لقب الدوري السعودي الطموح
المحلي لم يعد هو ما يعني جمهور الاتحاد
حتى الان بالتاكيد ارتفع سقف الطموحات
اكيد بس انه ايضا طموح المحلي نعرف انه
دائما عندما يقدم الفريق مستويات رائعه
على المستوى المحلي ينطلق
للاسيويه وينطلق للعالم ونعرف انه الاتحاد
ايضا لديه مهمه كبيره وهي مشاركه في كاس
العالم للانديه اللي تستضيفه المملكه
وبتدعيم للفريق
[موسيقى]
ليست وتحقيق نتائج جيده ومتوقع على فريق
الاتحاد في حالتها سابقه واذا ما اضيف له
بنزيما وكانتي وعدد من لاعبين الاخرين
لمتفائلين بحضورهم للمملكه وتدعيم الفرق
ومن ضمنها الاتحاد سيكون اتحاد قادر على
المنافسه في كاس العالم وايضا كاس اسيا
القادمه ما في شكل الاتحاد لسنوات طويله
ابتعد قليلا عن البطولات المحليه ذات
بطوله الدوري والمشاركه في
والمنافسه في بطوله اسيا ولكن الان يعود
بقوه ويعود بما يليق بالاتحاد وما نعرف عن
الاتحاد الجميل دكتور انت تحدثت قبل قليل
عن احتماليه انضمام ايضا
نقولو كانتي ايضا النجم الفرنسي المحبوب
والمعروف والذي بالتاكيد يعرفه كريم
بنزيما بشكل شخصي
هذه مثل هذه التدعيمات بالنسبه لناديه اهل
الاتحاد سترفع ايضا سقف طموحات بالنسبه
لبقيه الانديه في السعوديه لتع في مثل هذه
الجوده العاليه
بافضل لاعبين العالم كنا دائما ناخذ
لاعبين الصف الثاني والثالث واللاعبين
اللي قد تكون طموحاتهم في اوروبا بدات
تتلاشى ولكن اليوم انت تاخذ
الكره الذهبيه
20 22 وافضل لاعب في العالم كريستيانو
قبلها وش
اركوا
لتشيلسي ويلعب لمنتخب فرنسا يعني انت تاخذ
لاعبين في قمه مساهم في قمه عط
اءه وهذا ما يدعم الانديه انها تفكر ايضا
يعني حتى
النسبه للانديه وبالنسبه للجماهير اختلف
بعد ما كنا يعني نحلم بلاعبين جيدين الان
احنا لا يرضينا الا اللاعبين السوبر ستارز
وهذا المتوقع الحقيقه من الدوري ومن الدعم
الكبير ليحظى فيه هذا الدوري من اسمه زيدي
ولي العهد وايضا طموحات الانديه وشفناها
تحققت يعني ليست فقط طموحات واحلام ورديه
لا هي كريستيانو واحد من افضل لعيبه في
العالم في التاريخ وشفناه بنزيما الان هو
افضل لاعب 20 22 واللاعب النجم الكبير
واكثر من
حقق اعظم الانديه ريال مدريد واعتقد انه
البقيه تاتي وستكون على قدر الطموح
بالنسبه للانديه وبالنسبه للجماهيره خليك
روح لجده وايضا ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل
العربيه من ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله
الرياضي الزميل احمد الرايقي احمد اسمعني
بشكل جيد او صوت الاحتفالات يغطي على
الصوت
حقيقه الاجواء جميله جدا اليوم جدا كلها
تتكلم تقول ايه اليوم الحلو ده جماهير
الاتحاد تصلح بهذه الاغاني والاهازيج في
مدرجات ملعب الجوهره ولو انك تتابع معي
زميل محمد الان شوف هذه الجماهير يعني
صراحه
بكل حب
حضرت هنا من اجل بنزيما
ولانهم جيدا ليس يمثل الاتحاد وحده وانما
جزء كي رايه تجزا من
تمثيل المملكه العربيه السعوديه والرياضه
السعوديه وبالتالي
وبالتالي
[تصفيق]
ان
نزول الكابتن بنزيما الى ارضيه الملعب
[تصفيق]
عليها بعض الوقت بعد ذلك تبدا احتفالات
اخرى وبالتالي الجماهير بدات تتدفق منذ
وقت باكر الملعب الملعب الجوهره
احمد احمد احنا شفنا في الاخبار اليوم انه
الحضور الظهر احمد
الحضور الجماهير يا احمد اليوم ممكن
يتجاوز او يقترب من الخمسه وستين الف
متفرج وبالتالي احنا نتحدث عن واحد من
اكبر تقديمات اللاعبين في تاريخ كره القدم
على مستوى العالم انت من خلال اللي تشوفه
في المكان هل بالفعل الحضور الجماهيري قد
يصل الى هذا الرقم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وكان يتشاور مع عيلتي يقول يعني اكد ان
عائلتي اكدت له الحضور الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ايضا بنزيما اليوم شوهد
يتجول في احد المراكز التجاريه في جده على
الرغم من انه وصل يعني ليله امس لكن يعني
لعله حب كبير بينه وبينه مدينه جده خاصه
نؤكد انه
ينوي او يحب ان يترك اثرا جيدا هنا
خاصه مع جماهير الاتحاد وبالتالي
للمكان الكبير وللشعبيه الكبيره ليحظى بها
بنزيما
يعني صراحه من المتوقع ان يكون الاشياء
عظيم خصوصا يؤكد صداقه برونالدو واكد ان
الدوله السعودي سيكون عظيم الدوله السعودي
سيكون وجهه لكثير من لاعبين العالميين
احمد تابع معانا التغطيه راح نستمر معك
لكن خلني اروح للرياض والدكتور ترك العواد
منها الجزئيه التي تحدث فيها احمد كان
يقول بان
شهد احمد في احد المراكز التجاريه وايضا
انه يتجول براحته
هذا شاهدناه في كثير من اللاعبين الاجانب
لكن مثل هذه الاسماء دكتور من الصعوبه
دائما انها تنخرط بسرعه في المجتمع لكن
شاهدنا ايضا رونالدو يتفاعل مع المناسبات
الوطنيه في السعوديه ايضا يتفاعل حتى مع
حساب العلا حينما قال بانه يتمنى ان يزور
العلا خلال الايام المقبله ايضا نشاهد
بنزيما الان يتحدث عن
اهميه الارتباط بالمجتمع السعودي بشكل
كبير ما يدل على انه هذه عمليه استقطاب
اللاعبين سيكون لها ايضا تبعات على
المستوى الاجتماعي ايضا في السعوديه
صحيحه محمد هو شيء رائع جدا ودائما رائع
عليه في كل المجالات سواء في عندما نستضيف
بطولات عالميه او نستقطب لاعبين او
مؤتمرات او في كل المجالات الحقيقه ليس
فقط
في الرياض دائما نعول على الشعب
[موسيقى]
يعني يمكن احنا
نقوم بهذه الاشياء باب طبيعتنا وحفظنا
ولكن من ياتي للمجتمع السعودي اول شيء
لاحظه هو يعني كرم الناس واحبهم
واستقبالهم للاخرين بترحاب وكانه هو صاحب
البيت فلذلك ما استغرب ابدا انه من ياتي
للمملكه يتفاعل معها ويحبها ويصبح سفيرها
احنا كريستيانو وشفنا مش
كريستيانو لاعبين لسنوات طويله مش
اليوم عندما ياتون المملكه يغادرون
يغادرون بالدموع ويتمنون البقاء
المملكه
ودائمه الجيد وعندما يذهب احد من السعوديه
لدوله هذا اللاعب
تجده يستقبل الناس ودائما العالم السعودية
موجود
هذا السعودي وحب الاخرين والطبيعه الجميله
اضافه للت
قافه والارث الكبير موجود عند السعوديه
عندنا روح السعوديه موجوده اول ما يجي اي
شخص يجد له متفرده فهذه بالنسبه للاخرين
مجال رائع جدا واكتشفه حاجه جديده شيء
مختلف في روح حقيقيه للسعوديه لا يجدها
باي مكان اخر فلذلك هي ليست فقط رياضيه
وسيلعب في الملعب هو سيستمتع بالثقافه لها
تاريخ ضارب في القدم وايضا سيستمتع بالناس
وبكرمه وبحبهم فلذلك لا استغرب بنزين
بنزين طبعا قريب من المملكه وجاء وجار
المملكه وادى العمره ويمكن ادى الحج وهو
موجود لكن حتى بالنسبه للاخرين لمن ثقافات
اخرى وغير مسلمين نجدهم يتفاعلون مع
المملكه تفاعل اكثر وهذا بالنسبه لنا
واحده من المكاسب اللي ننقل الصوره
الحقيقيه للعالم من خلال السفر اللي ياتوا
للمملكه وكيف سياثر ذلك دكتور ايضا حتى
على التعاقدات المقبله يعني اللي ممكن
تيجي للسعوديه
يعني عندما تاكل فتح الباب للجميع واصبح
يعني اذا انت تجيب افضل لاعب في العالم ما
في شك انك قادر عن انك تحضر كثير من
اللاعبين لذلك ما في شكل شهيه مفتوحه
بالنسبه
نجوم من الصف الاول في اوروبا وفي امريكا
الجنوبيه الجانب الاخر انه العام بعد حضور
بنزيما وحضور كريستيانو وقد نرى نجوم
اخرين اتصور انه حتى انديه الوسط والانديه
الصاعده
انها تجيب نوعيه من اللاعبين اللي يلعبون
في افضل فريق اوروبا فهذا باب انفتاح
واعتقد انه سيبقى مفتوح وسنجد لاعبين يعني
يترون الدوري السعودي وايضا يزيدوا شعبي
حتى انا مستوى الحضور الجماهير اليوم في
التقديم دكتور نشاهد ايضا حتى
كثير من الحاضرين ليسوا حتى من المواطنين
السعوديين وبالتالي هذا سيرفع من ابن
شعبيه البطوله في وسط المقيمين في داخل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اذا ما عرفنا
انه في اخر احصاء ايضا للسكان بانهم
يقتربون من 43 او 44%
صحيح محمد هو طبعا اذا رجعنا للمؤتمر الصح
في سمو وزير الرياضه وتحدث في عن
السياحه بالرياضه وهذه جانب هام جدا يعني
وجود كريستيانو وجعل كثير من دول الخليج
ومن
خارج وشفنا ناس من اليابان وشفنا ناس من
اوروبا وعدد كبير من الاشخاص اللي ياتون
للمملكه فقط
لمتابعه مباريات
كريستيانو فايضا بنزيما
سيعطي هذا الزخم
مش بس الاجانب الموجودين في السعوديه
واللي هذا جزء من الترفيه والسياحه
المحليه ولكن حتى بالنسبه
للسياح الاجانب نعرف السعوديه اليوم انك
قادر على الحصول على الفيزا الكترونيا
ونعرف انه
حاصلين على الفيزا البريطانيه والامريكيه
قادرين على الحضور السعوديه بدون اي مشكله
فلذلك هي يعني منظومه متكامله بين
السياحه والترفيه والرياضه فعلا تجعل
الامور بالنسبه لنا في السياحه الرياضيه
هينه ومسهله والجميع قادرين على الحضور
فهي انت متابعه التلفزيونيه محمد شكلها
كريستيانو كيف الناس صارت تعرف الانديه
السعوديه وتعرف الاداء اللي فيها هي
مجموعه
اعتقد انه يعني هذا على المدى القصير طبعا
محمد
خلنا نروح الملعب
مدينه الملك عبد الله الرياضيه بجده وزميل
احمد الرايقي احمد متى ممكن يبدا الحفل
اذا عندك معلومه موثقه
ولكن يعني حتى الان
متاخر بعض الشيء
تاخر بعض الشيء ولكن
ربما في هذه اللحظات يعني على ما يقولوا
على
[تصفيق]
التفاعل صراحه بشكل كبير جدا يعني
فرحه كبيره وكان الاتحاد اليوم في الدوري
بالتالي
هم من اسبوع تقريبا توجوا في نفس الملعب
احمد بالدوري لكن لكن بحكم وجودك في
الاجواء الاحتفالات ومثل هالمناسبات تتسرب
عادل الاخبار تطلع القصص الجديده في اخبار
عن اللاعب الثاني اللي جاي للفريق خلال
الايام الجايه
[تصفيق]
والله الاخبار قويه جدا انه يعني الاتحاد
كبير جدا مع بعض المحترفين ما نقدر نسمي
اسم بعينه لكن هنالك ايش الكبير جدا قادم
للاتحاد ايضا
بعض المصادر ان الاتحاد ينوي ضم مجموعه
كبيره من اللاعبين في الفارسين ولربما
يعني وصول اولهم من سيما الى الاتحاد هذا
سيقري كثير من اللاعبين في اللحاف كابتن
كريم وبالتالي الامور
تقرب المايك شوي عشان نسمعك
من الاحاديث اقول لك يعني لعل وجود كريم
بنزيما في مقدمه المحترفين نادي الاتحاد
هذا سيدعم او سيساعد وسيسهم في لفت انتظار
كثير من اللاعبين المحترفين الاجانب يعني
في الدوري الاوروبي وجود بنزيما في
الاتحاد يغريهم بشكل كبير جدا وبالتالي من
المتوقع ان الاتحاد
سيحظى ببعض الاسماء القويه
ناهيك عن وجود رونالدو في النصر وبالتالي
وجود لاعبين من كبار وعمالقه كره القدم
الاوروبيه هذا سيعزز
حقوق بقيه الانديه انديه السعوديه في
احضار وجلب لاعبين محترفين على مستوى عالم
من اوروبا خلال الفتره المقبله اليوم
بصراحه نعيش اجواء جميله جدا يعني يعني
والجماهير اتفاعلت كثير مع بنزيما يعني في
وقت سابع مع ريال مدريد واليوم اكثر
البارحه منذ وصوله تواضع الجميل
اليوم رغم التعب اللي هو فيه وكذا لكن
ايضا يتجول في احد الاسواق يعطي انطباع
ومؤشر كبير على تقبل المجتمع السعودي
وجوده قبل شوي في المؤتمر يعني
بخلق روح كبيره بينه وبين الجماهير
السعوديه والجماهير الاتحاد السلفه بصفه
عامه الاجواء في المدرجات الان تتفاعل
بشكل كبير جدا
يعني الصراحه اجواء جميل احمد بعيد ما
شفنا في عقود احتراف بالشكل ده احمد حنرجع
لك ان شاء الله في في وقت لاحق لكن خلني
اروح للدكتور تركي من من الرياض الذي هو
معنا عبر الهاتف دكتور يعني في الايام
المقبله بالتاكيد سيكون هناك تحدي كبير
جدا
لكريم بنزيما حتى ان يثبت ان بالفعل قدومه
الى السعوديه ليس عمليه تقاعد بالتالي هذا
ما يتهم به بعض اللاعبين الذين ترتبط
اسمائهم بالقدوم الى السعوديه او حتى
الانتقال الى خارج ربما من بعض وسائل
الاعلام في اوروبا
عبد الله نوعيه اللاعبين يعني زي
كريستيانو وزي بنزيما عدد من اللاعبين لهم
اصلا لاعبين مقاتلين ونعرف انهم لا يرضون
بالخساره وسيبقى يقاتل والدوري السعودي
صعب يعني وقدم مستويات رائعه ومع هذا ما
قدر يساعد فريقه للحصول على الدوري فانت
محتاج بنزيما محتاج انه يقد
م مع الريال لمساعده الاتحاد عام المحافظه
على لقب الدوري وتق
ديم ايضا كبيره
في مجال ابدا لل
تحاور اصلا لاعب اللي وصل لهذه المرحله من
النجوميه ووصل لهذه المرحله من يعني
الاحترافيه ستجده يقاتل لانه الدوري
السعودي من دوريات صعبه
وكريستيانو تاكد على هذا الموضوع واكثر من
لاعب عندما حضر الدوري السعودي ما توقع
انه مستوى الفني مرتفع والنور والمباريات
حتى مع الفرق المهدده بالهبوط هو هي
مباريات صعبه ولا يمكن سهوله فلذلك بنزيما
بحاجه للقتاليه والاداء والاحترافيه
المعروفه عنه للبقاء في نفس الف اعتقد انه
هذا ما في خوف عليه جميل
الرئيس التنفيذي لناديه الاتحاد عبد
الوهاب عبد قال بان لدى الاتحاد رؤيه لان
يصبح افضل نادي سعودي يقدم كنموذج على
المستوى العالمي الان بدا الاتحاد في
التعاقد مع بعض الاسماء دكتور تعتقد بان
الاتحاد يحتاج الى الكثير حتى يصل الى هذه
المرحله التي قال عنها الرئيس والتنفيذي
لا ما يحتاج الكثير يعني الميزه بالاتحاد
انه هو بطل الدوري وانه فريقه فريق جيد
ومكتمل حتى قبل لا يجي بنزيما وقبل
التعاقد الصيفيه القادمه فلذلك هو محتاج
بعض التغييرات
اللي كانت في الفتره الماضيه مقلقه
بالنسبه للاتحاد
الفريق جيد ورائع ولديه هويه وشخصيه وانت
اصلا من مصلحه الفريق انه ما يغير كثير
يعني اذا قدر يستقبل ثلاثه لاعبين من
نوعيه بنزيما او اقل بشيء بسيط هذا بيكون
رائع لكن تغيير الفريق بشكل كامل حتى
بالنسبه للهلال حتى بالنسبه
عند التغييرات الكبيره في الفريق تفقده
الهويه وتجعله تعاني لسنوات خصوص الفريق
اللي مح
ققه وهذا برضو يعني رساله يجب ان تعيها
الجماهير انه
في القاعده الاجنبيه تقول لا تغير فريقا
ينتصر بشكل متواصل
صحيح
شفنا بعض نقاط الضعف الموجوده
في الموسم الماضي قدر انه
يتغلب ولكن قادر انه يستقبل لاعبين او
ثلاثه مع بنزيما
وهلا
عنده انك تخطئ اخطاء بعض الانديه اللي
فازت بالدوري ثم غيرت
لاعباله ان تدعم الفريق ما توقعت انه هذا
افقد الفريق لثقافه الانتصار وشخصيه
البطوله
واللي هو يعني
تراكم
مع الاتحاد انه
قبل لاعبين الى ثلاثه لعيبه مع بنزيما
ولكن لست مع التغيير الكامل والذهاب
لفتره الانتقالات الصيفيه بنعم وكانه فريق
للبناء اتحاد لا يحتاج للبناء الاتحاد فقط
يحتاج لتدعيم الفريق بعناصر معينه هو
يحتاجها في مراكز كانت ضعيفه في الموسم
الماضي خلنا نروح دكتور الى ملعب مدينه
الملك عبد الله نشوف وننضم للجماهير التي
تستمتع بهذه الاجواء الحبيبه تقديم نجم
الفريق الجديد الفرنسي كريم بنزيما الذي
انضم الى نادي الاتحاد في صفقه
سيمثله
ثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]
الجماهير ونشوف الاجواء وننضم الينا ايضا
في هذه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا نكمل هذه التغطيه معكم ومع
الزميل محمد القناص من داخل استوديوهات
العربيه محمد اليوم يعني يوم تاريخي ان
كان للمملكه وان كان لجماهير الاتحاد
والعشاق كره القدم بالسعوديه وبالمنطقه
ماذا يعني انضمام كريم البنزيما الى صفوف
الاتحاد الذي يقتبس من الكلام اللي قاله
الدكتور تركي العواد محل البرامج الرياضيه
والنشرات في لحظه تاريخيه بالتاكيد طبعا
بالنسبه لناديه الاتحاد لكن هذه اضافه
كبيره جدا للرياضه في المنطقه بشكل عام في
السعوديه بشكل خاص بالدوري السعودي
لمستقبل الرياضه الذي بدا يرسم بشكل واضح
خلال الاسبوع الحالي من خلال استحواذات
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه على اربعه انديه
السعوديه وبالتالي المستقبل ليس كما كان
في السنوات الماضيه نحن نتحدث عن خطوات
مقبله ربما تكون فيها كره القدم السعوديه
مختلفه تماما عما اعتادت عليه الجماهير
وعمه كانت تعتقد الجماهير بانه سيكون
عليها موضوع الاستثمار بالرياضه ونقل
الرياضه الى مكان مختلف تماما خصوصا كره
القدم بالمملكه هي بصلب الرؤيه رؤيه
المملكه 203 بيض صلب هذه الرؤيه المطلوب
ان تصل المنتخبات السعوديه او كره القدم
بالسعوديه الى مرتبات الانديه العالميه
كيف سيتحقق هذا الامر وعلى اي مستوى نتحدث
خلينا اول نتذكر انه الرؤيه رؤيه المملكه
2030 اكثر من شق حتى على المستوى الرياضي
لو تكلمنا عليها انه تحويل الرياضه من
طريقه ادارتها الهاويه الى طريقه محترفه
بشكل اكبر طريقه تعتمد على اداره روس
الاموال وبالتالي نتحدث عن مستقبل اخر
للرياضي نتكلم على اقتصاد ربما يصل الى
عشرات المليارات من الدولارات في المستقبل
لتكون رافدا ايضا سياحيا كبيرا جدا وعامل
جذب ايضا سياحي في الفتره المقبله
ايضا نتحدث عن
مستقبل اخر ايضا على المستوى الفني منتخب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قدم اداء جيد في
المونديال الاخير هو واحده من افضل
مستوياتها في كاس العالم وبالتالي يريد
المسير للشان في البلد سواء على المستوى
على مستوى البلد بشكل عام وحتى المسير
الرياضي ان يبني على هذا النجاح لمستقبل
الرياضه السعوديه ليصبح لدى السعوديه
منتخب ينافس على كاس اسيا التي تستضيف
السعوديه عام 2027 وايضا حتى على كاس
العالم او في كاس العالم 2026 التي ستقام
في
كندا وامريكا والمكسيك ايضا حتى لمستقبل
كره القدم السعوديه فيها 2030 ان يكون
لديها منتخب قويا عندما
نتحدث قوي نتحدث عن منتخب عربي قوي وعن
رؤيه مختلفه ويعني توجيه مختلف للرياضه
العربيه لتكون بمستوى الرياضه العالميه
يعني بالسنوات الماضيه لنكون صارحين كان
دائما يقال لا يمكن لاي منتخب عربي ان
يكون بمستوى المنتخبات العالميه او حتى
بمستوى الانديه العالميه ماذا يعني
التاسيس اليوم لمستقبل مختلف بعالم كره
القدم خلينا نتفق على جزئيه انه
ما قبل كاس العالم 2022 كان شيء وما بعده
شيء اخر يعني احنا دخلنا كاس العالم نعتقد
بان فقط مجرد اللعب في كاس العالم هو
الامتياز الذي يجب ان نحصل عليه شاهدنا
تجربه المنتخب السعودي مباراه امام
الارجنتين وحتى مباراتين خسرهم بعد ذلك لم
يخسر بسبب
سواء بسبب فوارق فنيه بسيطه لكن كان يقدم
مستوى ممتاز لكن الاهم من ذلك ايضا اداء
المنتخب المغربي والوصول الى نصف النهائي
ايضا شهاده المنتخب التونسي قدم اداء كبير
وهزم بطل العالم منتخب فرنسا وبالتالي
نتحدث على امكانيه
الانسان العربي على ان ينجح فيما لو توفرت
الظروف خطه السعوديه في الفتره المقبله ان
هذه الظروف ستوفر وبالتالي يجب على
الانسان العربي ان يرتقي ايضا كشاب كمواطن
عربي بمجهوده حتى يواكب مثل هذه المخططات
التي تقام وليتقدم ايضا ويصبح كما كما
يحدث في في اوروبا وفي كل مكان في العالم
والي وم يعني هذه الخطوات وهذا التاسيس
يثبت يعني يقول للمواطن العربي لا شيء
مستحيل يمكنك ان تقوم تقوم بالمستويات
العالميه مثل اي بلد يعني نحن فقط نحتاج
الى نموذج لنحتدي به شاهدنا ايضا نماذج
مشرفه على المستوى الرياضي على مستوى
السنوات الاخيره لكن كانت المشكله فقط في
توفير البيئه
للشباب حتى يحتذي بها كريم بنزيما يعني
بتصريحه الاخير او الاول لدى قدومه
وانضمامه للاتحاد يقول ليس فقط يعني بانه
يريد ويعشق العيش في المملكه وفي العالم
العربي وانما يعشق اللغه العربيه ويريد ان
يتعلم بطلاقه هذه الجزئيه هي ليست جزئيه
هي شيء اساسي جدا ان يعني ياتي اللاعب
الاول هو اليوم اللاعب الاول في العالم
يقول اريد ان اتعلم العربيه نحن نتحدث ليس
فقط عن تسويق الرياضه انما عن اللغه
العربيه
وكل هذا سينسحب على كل تفاصيل الحياه اذا
اعتاد العالم ان يشاهد الثقافه العربيه
بشكل متواصل سيحترمها بشكل اكبر وبالتالي
ستصبح ستنتشر بشكل اكبر جزئيه يعني قبل
اشهر تقريبا تناقل الجميع او كثير من
وسائل الاعلام انه تناقلوا مقطع فيديو
لاحد اطفال كريستيانو رونالدو يتحدث
بالعربيه في السعوديه وبالتالي مثل هذه
المقاطع ايضا لو شاهدناها من اكثر من نجم
جديد ياتي الى السعوديه ومن اطفالهم
سنشاهد بالتاكيد انعكاس ايجابي لها في
بلدانهم اولا ثم من خلال الناس اللي
يتابعوني ويحبونه ويعشقونهم احنا نتكلم
على ناس هم اكبر مؤثرين اكبر رياضيين
المؤثرين في العالم نتحدث عن متابعين
بالمليارات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وبالتالي سيكون سيكون مثير ومؤثر حقيقه
شاهد مثلث ثقافه الموجوده خلينا نشترك
زميلنا مراد المصري مراد مصري معانا مراد
انا مش عارف والله مراد انت مدريدي ولا
برشلونه ولا ايش بالضبط لكن بالتاكيد هذه
لحظه يشترك فيها جميع
الانديه وجميع جميع الفرق حدث انه استقطاب
لاعب كريم بنزيما اللاعب اللي حصل على
الكره الذهبيه العام الماضي يعني اخر موسم
كان هو
الذهبيه فازه مش من البعيد من السنه
الماضيه بس عم يتكلم يعني امر استثنائي
لانه لاعب كان غير متوقع تماما انه حتى
يترك ريال مدريد
وضع اسس واضحه الاستثمار المستقبل تحويل
ملكيه الانديه تحت صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه وحتى في توجهات ايضا اللي عندي
اخرى لتكون مع شركات خاصه هذا من اجل وضع
نظام ثابت وليس كما في سنوات السابقه ليس
فقط في السعوديه والبطل العربي بشكل عام
اللي هو دعم المحبين ودعم الهدف الصفقات
وغيرها
الانديه تنتظر يعني لا تعمل بطريقه
استدامه بعيد عن الاستدامه حاليا ما يحصل
هو الاستدامه لصلوات طويله وضع بناء عمليه
بناء نتكلم عنها الحديث عن المبلغ الذي
يتقاضاه بنزيما والهجوم الجدد القادمون
هذا اشبه بالاستثمار في بدايه مشروع انت
في بدايه اي مشروع يجب ان تدفع مبالغ
ماليه كبيره يعني
مهديه كبيره من اجل ان تحقق عائدات على
المدى الطويل انت لن تحقق عائدات خلال
الموسم او موسمين انت تتكلم عن خمس عشر
مواسم مقبله على الاقل تقدير زائدا عمليه
البناء بالمبالغ الكبيره بالوقت الحالي
لاحقا
ستصادق على استقطاب نجوم بمبالغ اقل مما
دفعتها في الوقت الحالي عندما يصبح دوري
دوري عالمي والنجوم موجودين اصلا سترى انه
جمل الاخرين هم من سيعرضون انفسهم عليك في
قادم السنوات بالتاكيد وبالتالي
خلينا نوضح جزئيه فقط انه بعض وسائل
الاعلام مراد تحدثت عن ارقام مبالغ فيها
لهذه الصفقه لكن هو فعليا عقد ناديه
الاتحاد مع كريم بنزيما هو راتبه السنوي
سيكون 55 مليون دولار فقط في طيله فتره
العقد لا اكثر من ذلك ليمثل نادي الاتحاد
طيب مراد حتى 55 مليون دولار ما تعتبر
راتب كبير جدا مقارنه باللي يتقاضى
اللاعبين في اللاعبون عفوا في في اوروبا
لمدينه تقريبا نصف هذا المبلغ يعني انت
دفعت في المبلغ من اجل
ريال مدريد وهذه الانديه هي النخب الاول
في العالم ليست عندي عاديه
وليس فرنسا يعتبر مثال او نانتي هو موجود
على ريال مدريد يعني حتى استمراره مع ريال
مدريد
لكن نادي ايضا امر
الاعلان عن هذه الارقام هو ما ما نتمناه
في الفتره المقبله بما انه الانديه اصبح
تتجه اصبح تحت اطار الخصخصه
تم
الكشف الاعلام الغربي يعني يقوم بعرض
مبالغ غير صحيحه يعني هذه واحده من الخفات
الايجابيه حتكون الفتى المقبله اللي هو
انه
الكشف يعول
ارقام ستقوم معلنه هذا من اجل تغيير نمط
اداره كره القدم
السعوديه وحتى العربيه يعني احنا دائما
الكره العربيه تتعامل لا تتعامل بالشفافيه
مع سيحصل في السنوات المقبله اتوقع من
خلال هذه سيكون هناك شفافيه هناك ارقام
هناك سجلات ماليه واضحه ايضا يستفيد منها
عمليه
تكون الاربعه انديه المنظمه لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه ستعامل بنظام يعني
حوكمه الشديد وايضا بالتالي سنشاهد كثير
من التفاصيل الماديه
والاداريه المقبله مختلفه في كره القدم
السعوديه لكن
خلني اسالك على مستوى العربي كيف سيكون
بامكان هذه التجربه ان تؤمن فائدتها على
المستوى العربي
فرصه الاحتكاك مع الهجوم عالميا من ناحيه
اخرى عده
حاليا قريب من الوسطره
العرب سيكون حلم
للاعب ضمن
حتى نحن معتاد
اللي كانت عند اللاعبين العرب في الاحتراف
الاوروبي على سبيل المثال انه
احتلال شر
ط
استراع و
غيرها موجود عم بياسس عربيه يعني يجمع بين
بين كل شيء الاسس العربيه والدينيه
الاسلاميه والعالميه يعني
اعتقد انه الجميع اللاعبين العرب الناشئين
والصاعدين في الوقت في السنوات المقبله
سيكون حلمهم ان يتواجدوا في هذا الدوري
واللعب فيه
اليوم من ضم اسماء كبيره نتحدث عن عمالقه
كره القدم الى الانديه السعوديه الى اي
مدى سيكون العنصر الاساس بتطوير الرياضه
ليس فقط كهوايه وانما وليس فقط كانديه
انما كمؤسسات وصناعه وسوق تجاريه للمملكه
وللمنطقه
الاستقطاب هذه الاسماء هي صدمه يعني
ايجابيه صدمه ايجابيه صدمه كبيره يعني
للمجتمع الكره والعالمي انه انتم استقطبت
الافضل وليس لاعبين في نهايه مسيرتهم فقط
اكمال مسيره يعني اسماء عابره على سبيل
المثال يعني كريستيانو رونالدو على سبيل
المثال هو عباره عن قوه اقتصاديه كبيره
قوه ترويجيه لوحده هو اله ترويجيه يعني
للترويج اكبر اكثر رياضي في العالم او شخص
حتى في العالم متابعه على الانستقرام على
سبيل المثال متابعين كبير على السوشيال
ميديا اعتقد ان وجود رو كريم بنزيما
والاسماء التي ستحضر ايضا في قادم الايام
كلها كفيله بنقل الصوره الايجابيه الترويج
سيكون لها اثر
تجاري يتحطى اطار الفوز والخساره يعني حتى
كان الحديث على سبيل المثال رونالدو
ومتابعه ما حققته من نتائج مع اعتقد مع
النصر اعتقد انه وجود رونالدو بحد ذاته
يتخطى اطار حسابات الفوز باللقب بالالقاب
من عدمها يعني هو نفسه عندما رونالدو كان
يسجل هدف على سبيل المثال وكالات الانباء
العالميه والصح
ف القبائل ما يقوم به وتقوم
بنقل شاهدنا دوري
موجود على اغلب من منصتي عالميه في الموسم
منذ الشتاء الماضي يعني الجميع كان يتابع
كل كبيره حتى ومن لا يتابع بشكل تفصيلي
كان يتابع عن عن عينه متابعه للدوري يريد
ان يعرف ما يحصل هناك
مراد داب معناه لكن سنذهب الى
لنشاهد ما قاله كريم بنزيما خلال المؤتمر
الصحفي
ثوره دخوله ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله
الرياضي لتقديمه لرسائل الاعلام ومن ثم
لجماهير كره القدم المتواجده في الملعب
نتابع
اخترت نادي اتحاد جده لانه فريق عريق
ودائما ينافس على الالقاب انا لاعب يحب
التحديات ولهذا السبب انا اليوم هنا في
هذا الملعب
الاتحاد يملك قاعده جماهيريه كبيره حفزتني
على الانتقال اليها والدفاع عن الوانها
حتى 2026
الجماهير السعوديه عامه تحب كره القدم
ولقد لاحظت ذلك سابقا عندما زرت هذا البلد
مع ريال مدريد اخترت نادي اتحاد جده من
اجل الاستمرار في حصد الالقاب لم افكر
طويلا عندما وصلني العرض انها تجربه جديده
ومثيره بالنسبه لي لانها بعيده عن القاره
الاوروبيه عامه وفرنسا على وجه التحديد كل
عائلتي سعيده بقدوم الى السعوديه وشجعتني
على قبول العرض وجدنا كل ترحاب هنا وانا
متاكد من انني اخترت الفريق الصحيح
لمواصله مسيره الكرويه
وايضا نرحب بالمحلل في قنوات العربيه
اللعبه السابق عادل البطيء الذي ينضم
الينا عبر الهاتف اهلا وسهلا بك كابتن
عادل حدث استثنائي كبير كنا شاهدنا مثله
في الرياض قبل اشهر اليوم
الطموحات الشارع الرياضي السعودي تصبح
اكبر نشاهد ايضا
عمليه تقبل وجود مثل هؤلاء اللاعبين
السعودي عفوا الاجانب الكبار في السعوديه
باتت اسهل
صحيح اخوي محمد
مشاهدي العربيه
الحقيقه احنا اليوم امام لاعب لاعب كبير
خلينا نقول بكل الحياه ما راح اقول لك
لاعب قبل سنتين ولا ثلاث قبل ايام هو لو
تشوف يعني الموسم هذا تحديد اول شيء الكره
الذهبيه حصل عليها الموسم
اليوم سجل كم 19 هدف من 24 مباراه من هو
هداف الدوري الاسباني ليفاندوفسكي
البولنديكي كم سجل 24 هدف من 34 مباراه
يعني احنا نتكلم عن لاعب كبير واحد اهم
لاعبي العالم في الفتره الحاليه اليوم مو
بامس عشان كذا اقول هو مكسب كبير كبير جدا
حتى اعجبني في تصريح اللي يقول انا يعني
اخترت شيء صح واقول احنا في الكره
السعوديه ان شاء الله اني اخترنا اللاعب
الصح اللي بيفيد الكره السعوديه ويفيد
طبعا نادي الاتحاد لكن الاهم بالنسبه لنا
دورينا بشكل عام استقطاب مثل هذا اللاعب
اللي سيرته يعني سيرته في كل الملاعب في
يعني يكفي جلس في 14 سنه في ريال مدريد
قصيره في فترات وعنده انكار الذاتي فترات
كان كان كما لو كان مساعد كريستيانو ومن
ثم اصبح النجم الهداء يعني كل هالامور
تقول اليوم احنا امام قامه كبيره في كره
القدم
عادل يعني اليوم الان بهذه الاثناء كل
وسائل الاعلام العالميه تنقل الخبر
الرياضي وتنقل الصوره من الرياض ومن ملعب
الاتحاد لهذا الحدث الاستثنائي نقل يعني
الصوره النمطيه للرياضه العربيه وتحديدا
السعوديه هنا وجعل هي محور الحديث على
العالمي وتحديدا الرياضي الى اي مدى
ستتطور مع انضمام لاعبين جدد والى اي مدى
يعني هي اليوم
بصلب اهميه ما يحصل
بصراحه سؤالك جميل ويعني له اكثر من مسار
اولا من ناحيه فنيه الاحتكاك مثل هؤلاء
اللاعبين يرفع من المستوى كيف في كره
القدم يقول لك
اثنين المنطق لما يكون متابع في كل العالم
مثل هذه الاسماء تجبر الاعلام الرياضي على
مستوى العالم بالنظر اليوم لما تتكلم عن
بنزيما الكل يسال حتى في كاس العالم
الاخيره اللي كان اسمه مدرج ولكن لم يشارك
الاصابه كان حديث الشارع في كل مره بنزيما
موجود او غير موجود حتى اللي اختلفوا مع
مد
المدرب منتخب فرنسا الكل كان يسال عن
بنزيما اليوم لما اتكلم عن حضوره للكره
السعوديه اعتقد انه مفيد ليس بس للكره
السعوديه او للدوري لكل ما انا ما ابغى
اتكلم عن نواحي اقتصاديه اللي مو بتخصصي
لكن فعلا الامر اكبر من مستطيل اخضر
يتواجد به لاعبين مفيد للكره السعوديه على
حتى على مستوى منتخبات في كره القدم نحتاج
النماذج يعني حتى من الفئات السنيه من سن
الاكاديميات 8 سنين وعشره الكل يتحدث عن
نجم عن كليه تحدث يريد ان يكون له قدوه في
الملائكه السعوديه ما بالك موجود عدد من
اللاعبين واليوم امس كريستيانو واليوم
بنزيما والقادم ان شاء الله افضل لكن انا
بصراحه يعني خلينا نقول على المستوى
الشخصي احد المحبين والمعجبين جدا في
بنزيما ليش قبل ان تجد لاعب في هذا يعني
دائما احنا نقول راس حربه تقليدي نواحي
فنيه اليوم هذه العبرات حربه تقليدي ويلعب
تس عه ونص ويطلع بره يعني كل الامور هذه
الامور
الفنيه كابتن عادل راح نناقشها في لما نجي
نتكلم عنه فنيا مع الاتحاد لكن اليوم احنا
نرحب فيه ترحيبه
فنيه ويزعل علينا طيب
محمد انا متفق معاك ويمكن يمكن انا دائما
يجروني الموضوع حكم تخصصنا للنواحي الفنيه
لكن بدون شك بدون شك يا محمد احنا امام
حدث تاريخي انه مثل هذا اللاعب يعني زي ما
قال الاخ مراد قبل شويه هو مو طالع من
يعني من المستوى به في اوروبا طالع من
اعظم نادي في اوروبا بصراحه في السنوات
الاخيره يكفي انك تتكلم عن ريال مدريد ومن
ثم تقول هداف ريال مدريد منهم يؤثر على
على المشهد العام في المنطقه وليس على
مستوى الكره السعوديه انا اشوف احيانا
اتعمد اتابع بعض القنوات العربيه حقيقه
الحديث عن كريستيانو فتره طويله اليوم انا
امس اشوف بعض القنوات تتكلم عن تعاقد نادي
الاتحاد مع بنزيما هذا اثرها على فكره على
المدى الطويل شيء شيء مهم جدا ولاحظ انه
يقول اني انا ما ما ترددت فيه اختيار لانه
زار المنطقه اكثر من مره عندنا وكيل انه
قربه ايضا من مكه طبعا
احمد الرايق يا احمد
واضح انه يبدو انه بدات الجماهير يعني
تغلق كافه المساحات الملعب احمد وبالتالي
يعني ربما يكون الدخول بنزيما الان
هم عندهم صراحه خبر الظاهر الجمهور في
الملعب اكثر منا
الاصوات عندي قويه ولكن يبدو انك كاني
سمعت انك سالت عن الجماهير او الحضور
الجماهيري
انا اقول الجمهور واضح انه عنده خبر متى
يبدا الحفل اكثر منه
وبالتالي انه الملعب
من المفترض ان يدخل للاعب هذا اخر ما
سمعنا فيه قبل شوي
كريم بنزيما ارضيه الملعب راح يلف على
المدرجات على حي الجماهير حيكون زي
الاتحاد ويبدو الان بدات الاضاءه تنحفظ
يبدو انه الان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]
كنت واقفين معه في اي مكان
ولما فاز انتم حفله وحلاوه الذريق وحلاوه
الفوز
بما انكم جمهور الذهب
الاتحادية
بس قبل لا ندخل في بيناتنا الجميله اليوم
ان شاء الله كلنا في اوقات جميله
بطني بقينا لاعب كبير
خلونا نتابع معكم فيديو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا لحظات وينطلق برنامج حفل التقديم نجم
نادي الاتحاد الجديد الفرنسي كريم بنزيما
الذي بدا قبل قليل
بعرض بسيط عرض فيديو بسيط لمسيرته الطويله
التي بدات منذ ما يقارب سته عشر عاما او
17 عاما مع نادي ليون الفرنسي حقق فيها
اربعه القاب دوري وكاس فرنسا
وثلاث كاس ثلاث بطولات محليه اخرى وايضا
مع ريال مدريد الجميع يعرف بطولاتها الخمس
والعشرين التي حققها مع نادي الاتحاد او
عفوا مع نادي ريال مدريد وبالتاكيد يريد
ان يواصل مسيره التتويج بالالقاب ومسيره
الذهب الطويله مع نادي
الاتحاد كريم يبدو انه ولد وعلى رقبته
ميداليه ذهب
اذا سيكون المكان المناسب له الاتحاد بطل
الدوري السعودي لكره القدم تابع هذا العرض
المباشر من ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله
الرياضيه بجده عرض الدرونز الترحيبي
بالنجم
الفرنسيه
في السماء
كنايه عن لقب نادي الاتحاد المعروفه
بالنمور في
السعوديه وهم ينظمون الجديد اليوم يرحبون
به في
الملعب الجوهره الذي شهد قبل اسبوع تقريبا
تتويجهم بلقب الدوري السعودي بعد 14 عاما
من الغياب عن منصه في تتويجه الدوري
السعودي وان كان النادي لم يغب عن التتويج
بالالقاب سبق وان توج بلقب كاس السوبر
السعودي الموسم
الجاري ايضا
اذا بانتظار دخول المتوج بجائزه افضل لاعب
في العالم افضل لاعب في العالم حتى الان
كريم بنزيما لتقديمه لجماهير نادي الاتحاد
التي استشهدت في ملعب مدينه الملك عبد
الله الرياضيه ترحيبا بابرز واحدث
المنضمين الى النادي الجداوي هذا الموسم
والاسم الاول في قائمه انتقالات الصيف
الاتحاديه التي ربما
ستشهد انضمامنا مزيد من النجوم مزيد من
الاسماء الكبيره التي ستمثل بطله الدوري
السعودي في النسخه المقبله من كاس العالم
للانديه ايضا التي تستضيفها السعوديه
نهايه العام الجاري وبالتالي سيكون
الاتحاد
انبار وسائل الاعلام
المحليه والعربيه والعالميه في النسخه
المقبله من كاس العالم للانديه والتي
ستشهد مشاركه اما انتر ميلان الايطالي
ايضا او مانشستر سيتي ايهما سينجح في
التفويس بلقب دوري ابطال اوروبا السبت
المقبل سيتواجد في الرياض ايضا لمشاركه في
هذه البطوله
[تصفيق]
لقطات المباشره من ملعب مدينه الملك عبد
الله الرياضيه الملعب الجوهره في جده عروس
البحر الاحمر التي تزدان اليوم
للترحيب بالنجم الجديد المنضمة لنا
الاتحاد كريم بنزيما النجم الفرنسي الذي
قدم من ريال مدريد بعد مسيره ممتده 14
عاما مع نادي الملكي بدات عام 2009 وشهاده
التتويج
بخمسه 2020
كاسا طيله هذه الفتره خمس منها فكانت او
خمسه القارب منها كانت دوري ابطال اوروبا
وخمسه كؤوس في عالم
للانديه والقاب عديده محليه ايضا نجح فيها
بنزينه بان يضع بصمته
ليصبح احد ابرز قاده الفريق الملكي نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كبير خرج من الباب الكبير لجائزه
البولاندول
فقط اللاع
ب
جاء الوقت للترحيب في لاعب نادي الاتحاد
الجديد
كريم كريم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بك كريم شكرا
[تصفيق]
انه لا شرف عظيم
ان نراك هنا في جده مع جماركما 60 الف من
المشجعين الذين جاؤوا لرؤيتك
[تصفيق]
اود ان اقول شكرا جزيلا
املوا ان شاء الله
اننا سوف
ننجز الكثير ونرفع من مقام النادي
[تصفيق]
السؤال الاول الذي يطرح
هو لماذا اخترت الاتحاد اخترته الاتحاد
لانه نادي
جيد وقد فاز بالدوري
طبعا النادي لديه جماهير رائعون
[تصفيق]
وبتاكيد سوف ابذل كل ما على الملعب لجعل
النادي في مكان اعلى بكثير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اود ان اقول
معنا
شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
كريم عندنا تس
[موسيقى]
على هذا الحب وانا سعيد جدا لتواجد هنا
وان شاء الله سوف ننكر الكثير معا ان شاء
الله
اود ان اقول اهلا بك في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه انا متحمس جدا ان تكون مع ان من
اجل تحدي جديد ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا تابعنا مشاهدينا مراسم احتفال ناديه
الاتحاد السعودي بانضمام اللاعب العالمي
كريم بنزيما الى النادي وسط جماهير غفيره
فرحه بهذا الانضمام وهو الحاصل على الكره
الذهبيه لافضل لاعب في العالم من استاد
الجوهره تفاصيل اكثر طبعا حول هذا
الانضمام وسط الجماهير الكبيره التي
نشاهدها والفرحه العارمه طبعا في النشره
الرياضيه خلال هذه
ونشرات الاحقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات